AS
>> PRESIDEELENSKYY SPEAKINR THE.
RE WE ?
SPF
HE ORDEREDST ON
RUSSIAN TERRITORY,NDHIS WAS
ANER.
THIS IS WH HE SAID.
>> Translator: I DO NOS
ANY OF MRSMMANDER IN
E LEADER O STATE,
NEED TO UNDETAMENTD,HAVEO OW, T
FROM UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS,
NEMING NOR DENYI
THAS RESTH AAYLOT.
AND  TALKET HOS
THAT FUE THAT WOULD MAKE
IT AE MILITARYAR
>> AND NOW, ATYL, FIS WARNING TY
H LE
RADIATION?
SOLDIERSTH MAY HAVE BEEN
ENCHES IN TH
HE PERIMETERE NUCLEAR WEPLT.OF I
ALSO, WE'RE HEARING FROM
D COMPANY
FO TN SOLDIERS  DRIVING HEAVIRM
HIGH L OF
EXPORECTIVITY, IT
S THE ORGANS, BONERO
AND IT COULD BE
THIS HEANGRNOBYLFI WHAT
HAEN
WONDE W, I THINK  FLU COLD.BUTI
>> T
ONHE ATTACK ON THE FUEL DEPOT  K
PENETRATING RUSSIA
CIDENTABTHRUTA
ON APRIL 1stT AROUND
MOSCOW TIME,ANS ENTERED THAI
DERATION, TSPOKESMAN SA A
AS A RESULT, INDIVL S  AND CAUG.
VIDEO SHOWS THTY
ENGULFED ITHE
FIREFIGHTERSTRUGGLING TO PUT
E FL
HIGHLLID CITY
JUST OUTSIDE OF UKINE.E TARY SUA
ACKNOWLEDGEDHAT THT.
>>EI CONFIRMORREJECT THE CLAIM T
S INVOLVED IN THIS.
ALE MILITARY INFORMATION.ter: TE
SUFFERING SETBACKS IN THEIR
UKRAINE.
WIDRS FROM
AROUNDV
WANT TO FOCUS THEIR OFFENSIVONS,
KHARKIV,A
ASO TR ENDG IN
GHTING CONE.
VLADIMIPU
BRIEFED ON THE DEPOT ATTACK, AND
WILLRO LITOLE A NEGATIVE EFFECTI
UP RUSSIF RAINE.
IFHES ARE BEHIND
, IT WOULDEY'RE
AFRAID TO STRIKE BONY THAT IS AN
AND THE RUSSIANS. MUCH.TURETIREI
IT'S THEAR
HORSE WHEN IT COME TANKS AND
KIND OF ARMOR.UKRAINIANS WOU B
WHATHEN DOEM IS  V AREA GHT HER.
USE THEM TO GO AFTER RUSANFORCE
THE .
THE RUSSIAAVE TELEGRAPHED
TH TRENG TO INTO INT
EASTERNN WHIC
AD OUEREDOF.
THESE AREAS.
TH POTENTIALLY A BITA NGER FOR .
COLONEL, I'VE BEEN WANT
TH
STRIKE ON A FUEL
EXPLAIN WHY TH IS SUCH AH TARGEA
BESAW HETHAT IT UP
HERE, KHARKIV IS HERE.
AN AREA WHE
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN WORKING QUITE
A BIT, EVER SINCE THE START OF
EE
THIS IS THEIR FUEL DEPOT.
ISAT THE
TO
THESE ARE THONES THAT GET EL IRI
SEE, THERE'S A CETES INTO THE F.
AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER -
AND THERE, A COUPLE TRIKES E  S
HEPTS MEAN, THEY HAD
ISE INTELLIGENCE O
W EXACTLY
WH T.
IT CRITICAANTHEITERMOF
MLY
THNESSN AI
DEFENSE SYSTEM IME FRO
>> NEW SATELLITE HAVAIRPOR8 MIL
FROM KYIV.L T?
COULD IT HELP S
>> POTENTIALLY IT DEPN HOWHAT
FT
ESTING
IT WASAKEN ON MARCH 21st
THIS IR BEFORE IMAGEOU LOOK CLOE
THAT TRUCKS ANY PIECESARE IN PL
THESE BERMS RIHERE.
THAT BUILT.
TH TIRERE
HERE'S A TANK IN
E AREAS. DIDHI T
AIRP
AN A AFTERS.
RIGHRELL BERIGHTED
MP.
A SSIAN
SO THIS , MAY
HAVE TO BE R TUSE, AS S
B TARGETED BY
LLERY OR A VERY INTERESTING,EL.
WHR E?NTON THE U.S. IS SENDI00ED
HELP S IS POTENTIALLY SOMNG
SWITCHEE U.S.
USI IT.
IT'S CALLED A ICONE,
CAN GO RIGHTANY
DESTROYS ITSELF.
AND AS YOU SEEITY EA LAUNCD CA